>> Jon: WELCOME BACK! MY GUESTS
TONIGHT, THEY ARE THE CREATORS,
WRITERS AND STARS OF COMEDY
CENTRAL'S GREAT "BROAD CITY."
>> ABBI?
>> PRANK! YES!
>> DUDE, I JUST SAW THE HOTTEST
GIRL I HAVE EVER SEEN.
WE HAD THE MOST INCREDIBLE
SPARK.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I HAVE TO FIND HER.
>> I DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
>> HERE, TAKE MY TICKETS.
>> WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
THESE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOR
THE COATS.
>> NO, WE PUT THE TICKETS IN THE
TIP JAR AT THE END OF THE NIGHT
THEN PEOPLE FIND THEIR MATCHING
TICKET.
THAT PROVES THE COAT'S THEIRS.
THAT'S HOW COAT CHECK WORKS.
>> NO THAT'S NOT HOW COAT CHECK
WORKS.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE ON THE
HANGERS WITH THE CORRESPONDING
COAT.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALWAYS
ENCOURAGING ME TO FOLLOW MY
HEART. I LOVE YOU.
>> AGAIN, THAT'S NOT WHAT I
SAID. [BLEEP]
>> Jon: PLEASE WELCOME ABBI
JACOBSON AND ILANA GLAZER!
C'MON OUT HERE!
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: YOU! SO NICE TO SEE YOU.
COME AND SIT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME!
>> OH, MY GOSH!
>> Jon: I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING...
HERE'S -- MAY I?
MAY I TELL YOU SOMETHING?
>> PLEASE, PLEASE.
>> PLEASE DO.
>> Jon: I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THAT SHOW IS
JOY.
YOU SOMEHOW TRANSLATE JOY TO
THAT SHOW.
IT IS SUCH A RARE QUALITY IN
THIS STUPID, STUPID BUSINESS TO
BRING A JOYFUL EXPRESSION OF
YOUR COMEDY TO THE SCREEN.
I LOVE IT.
>> WE CAN'T EVEN HANDLE
THIS. WE CAN'T HANDLE IT.
IT'S CRAZY THAT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT. THANK YOU.
>> Jon: I'M GOING TO START TO
CRY.
I THINK WE'RE ALL GOING TO START
TO CRY.
>> I'M NOT CRYING.
>> Jon: I'M NOT CRYING,
EITHER.
>> I DON'T CRY.
>> Jon: I'M MADE OF ONIONS. I
TOLD THE PEOPLE EARLIER.
>> I'M NOT GONNA CRY AT ALL. WE
SWORE WE WOULDN'T CRY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: HOW ARE YOU HANDLING
THIS?
IS IT, WHEN DID THIS HIT FOR YOU
WHEN YOU REALIZE, LIKE (BLEEP)
THIS IS IT.
THIS IS BIG TIME!
>> THIS MOMENT RIGHT HERE IS --
>> IT'S A GOOD INDICATOR, YOU
KNOW. FAIR INDICATOR.
>> IT'S HAPPENING.
>> Jon: NO, NO. NO.
>> BUT I THINK THAT WE
WERE LUCKY ENOUGH THAT
WE HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
THE WEB SERIES BEFORE.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> SO IT FELT LEGITIMATE TO US
BEFORE, WE HAD TO VALIDATE
OURSELVES BEFORE OTHER
PEOPLE DID --
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND I THINK THAT REALLY FORMS
THE EXPERIENCE WHICH FORMS THE
PRODUCT.
>> Jon: DOES IT SEEM DIFFERENT?
YOU KNOW, SOMEONE WAS TALKING
TO ME EARLIER ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
I'M TRYING TO GET INTO COMEDY
WRITING AND ALL THAT, IT FEEL
LIKE THERE'S MORE OPPORTUNITY
THAN THERE EVER WAS FOR PEOPLE.
IT'S BEEN DEMOCRATIZED
TO SOME EXTENT.
>> YEAH.
>> YEP.
>> Jon: DO YOU THINK A SHOW LIKE
THIS, VOICES LIKE YOURS, UNIQUE
AND JOYFUL COULD HAVE GOTTEN
ON THE AIR WITHOUT THE WEB?
>> I DON'T THINK SO, NO.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> NOPE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: WAS IT HARD?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, WE BOTH CAME UP
AT THE UPRIGHT CITIZENS BRIGADE.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> WOOT WOOT!
>> TAKING CLASSES, AND GOT
REALLY --
>> Jon: GREAT PLACE.
>> YEAH. WONDERFUL PLACE.
AND WE GOT REALLY TUNNEL
VISIONED INTO LIKE WELL,
THE ONLY WAY TO MAKE IT IS TO
GET ON A HOUSE TEAM AND YOU
GOTTA DO THAT AND IF YOU DO
THAT THEN YOU DO THE NEXT AND
LIKE, YOU KNOW --
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN FOR
US.
AND THEN WE WERE SORT OF
LIKE NEEDING SOMETHING TO SEND
OUR PARENTS TO PROVE THAT WE
WERE, IN FACT, DOING COMEDY.
>> SEND THEM A LINK.
>> Jon: AND YOU KNOW HOW TO
USE THIS INTERNET.
>> JON, COME ON.
>> THEY CAN CLICK A LINK IN AN
EMAIL.
>> Jon: REALLY?
>> AND IT'D JUST SHOW, THE WEB
EPISODE WOULD JUST SHOW UP.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THEY DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO
PRESS PLAY. IT LOADS, YOU KNOW.
>> Jon: NOW DO THEY UNDERSTAND
AT THIS POINT THAT THERE IS A
SUBTLE SEPARATION BETWEEN
THAT AND TELEVISION?
LIKE DID THEY UNDERSTAND ONCE
YOU GOT ON COMEDY CENTRAL
DID THEY THINK LIKE OH YEAH,
THAT'S YOUR WEB SERIES OR
THAT'S A NETWORK ON THE BOX.
I DON'T HAVE TO CLICK ANYTHING.
>> YOUR PARENTS HAVE A HARDER
TIME DISTINGUISHING, RIGHT?
LIKE WEB -- MY MOM WOULD TELL
PEOPLE LIKE A LOT OF TIMES, LIKE
SHE'S ON YOUTUBE! SHE'S ON
YOUTUBE!
WITH NOT REALLY KNOW, LIKE
REALIZING, LIKE YOU PROBABLY
ARE, TOO, MOM, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY IS!
>> Jon: I REALLY ENJOYED, SO
THEY WERE KIND ENOUGH TO DO
NIGHT OF TOO MANY STARS, DO THE
TELETHON. DO THE PHONE BANK.
AND IN THE MIDDLE OF IT, SO THE
WHOLE IDEA IS YOU CALL, YOU PAY
SOME MONEY, YOU CALL THE
PHONE BANK AND GET TO
TALK TO ABBI AND ILANA.
WELL, ONE OF THE CALLS THAT CAME
IN FOR ABBI, IT WAS ABBI'S MOM.
>> OH, IT WAS SO CUTE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> IT, OH, IT MADE ME LOVE MY
MOM SO MUCH.
>> Jon: DID SHE HAVE TO PAY?
>> SHE DEFINITELY PAID.
>> OH SHE PAID.
SAMANTHA BEE CAME OVER, ILANA
AND I, SO THIS NIGHT WAS
AMAZING.
>> Jon: IT WAS A GREAT NIGHT.
>> IT WAS SO AMAZING.
BUT ALSO WE WERE, LIKE, THIS IS
NUTS.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> SO SUSAN SARANDON WAS SITTING
LIKE IN FRONT OF US.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND I'M, LIKE, ILANA, WE'RE
GOING OVER AND WE'RE
GOING TO SAY HELLO
TO SUSAN SARANDON.
>> ABBI LIKE USES ME AS LIKE A
SHIELD WITH LARRY DAVID AND
SUSAN SARANDON.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> WE'RE GOING.
>> AND SHE LIKE HERE WE ARE. AND
I WAS LIKE --
>> Jon: NOW, YOU DON'T SEEM LIKE
A RELUCTANT WARRIOR, THOUGH.
WHEN SHE SAID WE'RE GOING, WERE
YOU LIKE ALL IN, HANDS IN,
CLEAR EYES, FULL HEART,
CAN'T LOSE, LET'S DO THIS?
>> THAT'S BROAD CITY, BABY!
THAT'S BROAD CITY.
>>THAT'S HOW WE DO IT.
>> Jon: THATS BROAD CITY.
LET'S DO THIS. THAT'S HOW WE DO.
>> YEAH.
SO WE'RE TALKING TO SUSAN
SARANDON ABOUT IMPORTANT
POLITICAL ISSUES.
>> Jon: WHAT DO YOU, WHAT DO YOU
THROW OUT AS THE FIRST THING?
DO YOU GO LIKE, ATLANTIC CITY,
WOW!
OR WHAT DO YOU DO? WHAT DO YOU
DO?
>> LET'S GO! WE DID -- I THINK
WE DID, HELLO, MS. SARANDON.
>> SAID LIKE, YOU'RE A QUEEN.
YOU KNOW, THANK YOU FOR BEING
LIKE SUCH A BAD BITCH BECAUSE
THAT MAKES THE WORLD
A BETTER PLACE.
>> Jon: RIGHT. YOU WENT RIGHT AT
IT.
>> YEAH. YOU GOT TO.
>> YOU DON'T HOW MUCH TIME
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
>> WE DON'T KNOW -- THIS COULD
BE IT.
>> Jon: YOU THINK SHE WOULD HAVE
GIVEN YOU THIS. YEAH.
>> YEAH.
>> DONE. AND HER SECURITY LIKE
MOVES US AWAY.
>> Jon: RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT,
RIGHT. RIGHT, INTERESTING.
>> YEP, AND SO SAMANTHA BEE
POLITELY CAME OVER AND SAID,
ABBI, YOU HAVE A CALL. AND I WAS
LIKE OH --
>> Jon: THIS IS A TELETHON.
>> I WAS LIKE --
>> Jon: YOU CAN'T HAVE A CALL IN
A TELETHON.
>> SO YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF CALLS.
>> SHE SAID YOU HAVE A CALL,
IT'S YOUR MOM.
AND, LIKE, I TALK TO MY MOM
EVERY DAY.
LIKE I TALKED TO HER EARLIER
THAT DAY.
>> YOU TALKED TO HER EARLIER --
YEAH.
>> AND I WENT, I GO OVER --
>> FOR FREE. FOR COMPLETELY
FREE.
>> Jon: I LOVE THIS! IT'S
AMAZING!
>> AND I GO OVER AND I'M, LIKE,
HEY!
>> SHE'S SO, LIKE, YOU'RE DOING
IT RIGHT NOW AREN'T YOU?
I DO A THING WHERE I DO
THIS OLD CAROL BURNETT THING
FOR MY MOM.
>> Jon: FOR YOUR MOM, REALLY?
>> AND THEN SHE'LL SEE IT.
>> AND SHE'S GOES, DO IT, DO IT!
>> BUT IT WASN'T LIKE A TAPED
SEGMENT.
>> AND IT WAS LIKE, IT'S NOT A
--
>> Jon: ON THE TELETHON.
>> SO I'M DOING IT, BUT IT WAS
NOT A TAPED SEGMENT.
>> YEAH, SO IT WAS LIKE NOT
LIVE.
>> Jon: OH MY GOD.
>> WELL, I JUST DID IT A LOT.
>> Jon: JUST NOW.
>> A LOT JUST NOW.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW WHAT?
CAN I TELL YOU, CAN I TELL YOU
THE CALL I'M ABOUT TO GET?
SO AS I WAS WATCHING THE SHOW.
IT SEEMS THAT ABBI DOES A
GESTURE TO HER MOTHER.
(LAUGHTER)
WHICH IS UH, JUST TO TELL HER
MOTHER SHE'S THINKING ABOUT
HER AND THAT'S IT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A NICE GESTURE AND
A QUITE SIMPLE ONE!
>> YOU'VE NEVER DONE IT! YOU'RE
ON EVERY NIGHT.
>>YOU COULD DO IT. YEAH, YOU
COULD DO ONCE BEFORE THE SHOW.
I'M SORRY, BUT DELAY THE GUILT.
>> Jon: I GOT TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING.
DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOUR
MOM?
>> WHAT UP, MOM! I DON'T KNOW.
WHOO!
MOM AND DAD, I LOVE YOU!
>> Jon: OH YOU'RE GONNA
THROW UP A LITTLE.
YEAH, ALL RIGHT, I'LL DO
SOMETHING.
I'LL GIVE LIKE A LITTLE
THING FOR MY MOM.
>> YEAH, DO IT!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: THAT'S ALL I GOT.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH
I HAVE BEEN ENJOYING THE SHOW,
ENJOYING THE TWO OF YOU.
>> SUCH AN HONOR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> Jon: I'M TELLING YOU, YOU'RE
BRINGING JOY.
NOTHING BETTER THAN THAT.
>> AH THANK YOU!
>> Jon: BROAD CITY AIRS
WEDNESDAY NIGHTS 10:30 ON
WHAT'S THE NETWORK?
>> IT'S COMEDY CENTRAL.
>> COMEDY CENTRAL!
>> COMEDY CENTRAL! ABBI JACOBSON
AND ILANA GLAZER!